Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
with Dr. Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
Most people think that if we have a piece
of camera footage that is a little choppy,
then there is nothing we can do with it, we
better throw it away.
Is that true?
No, not at all!
Earlier, we discussed two potential techniques
to remedy this common problem.
The problem statement is simple, in goes a
choppy video, something happens, and then,
out comes a smooth and creamy video.
This process is often referred to as frame
interpolation, or frame inbetweening.
And of course, it’s easier said than done.
If it works well, it really looks like magic
- much like in the science fiction movies.
So what are the potential somethings that
we can use to make this happen?
One, optical flow.
This is an originally handcrafted method that
tries to predict the motion that takes place
between these frames.
This can kind of produce new information and
I use this in these videos on a regular basis,
but the output footage also has to be carefully
inspected for unwanted artifacts.
Which are a relatively common occurrence.
Two, we can also try to give a bunch of training
data to a neural network, and teach it to
perform this frame inbetweening.
And if we do, the results are magnificent.
We can do so much with this!
But wait a second…if we can do this for
video frames… here is a crazy idea - how
about a similar kind of inbetweening…for
animating humanoids?
That would really be something else and it
would save us so much time and work!
Let’s see what this new method can do in
this area!
The value proposition of this technique is
as simple as it gets: we set up a bunch of
keyframes, these are the transparent figures,
and the neural network creates realistic motion
that transitions from one stage to the next
one.
Look, it really seems to be able to do it
all, it can perform twists and turns, brisk
walks and runs, and you will see in a minute,
even dance moves.
Hmm…this inbetweening for animating humanoid
motion idea may not be so crazy after all!
What’s more, this could be super useful
for artists working in the industry, who can
not only do all this, but they can also set
up movement variations by moving the keyframes
around spatially.
Or we can even set up temporal variations
to create different timings for the movement.
Excellent.
Of course, it cannot do everything, if we
set up the intermediate stages in a way that
uncommon motions would be required to fill
in, we might end up with one of these failure
cases.
And all these results depend on how much training
data we have with the kinds of motions we
need to fill in.
Let’s have a look at a more detailed example!
This smooth chap has been given lots of training
data with dancing moves, and…look!
And when we pull out these dance moves from
his training data, he becomes a drunkard.
So, talking about training data.
How much motion capture footage was given
to this algorithm?
It used the Ubisoft La Forge Animation Dataset.
This contains 5 subjects, 77 sequences, about
4.5 hours of footage in total.
Wow, that is not that much.
For instance, it only has 8 movement sequences
for dancing.
That is not that much at all.
And we’ve already seen that the model can
dance.
That is some serious data efficiency, especially
given that it can even climb through obstacles.
So much knowledge has been extracted from
so little data.
It truly feels like we are living in a science
fiction world.
What a time to be alive!
So, when we write a paper like this, how do
we compare the results to previous techniques?
How can we decide which technique is better?
Well, the level 1 solution is a user study.
We call some folks in, show them the footage,
ask which one they liked best - the previous
method, or this one?
That would work, but of course, it is quite
laborious, but fortunately, there is a level
2 solution.
And this level 2 solution is called the Normalized
Power Spectrum Similarity, NPSS in short.
This is a number that we can produce with
a computer, no humans are required, and it
measures how believable these motions are.
And the key of NPSS is that it correlates
with human judgement, or in other words, if
this says that a technique is better, then
it is likely that humans would also come to
the same conclusion.
So let’s see.
Here are the previous methods, NPSS is subject
to minimization, in other words, the lower,
the better.
And, let’s see the new method…oh yes,
it indeed outpaces the competition.
So, there is no wonder that this incredible
paper was accepted to the SIGGRAPH ASIA conference.
What does that mean exactly?
If research were the olympics, a SIGGRAPH
or SIGGRAPH ASIA paper would be the gold medal.
And, this was Mr. Felix Harvey’s first few
papers.
Huge congratulations!
And as an additional goodie, it can create
an animation of me when I lost my papers,
and this is me when I found them.
Do you have some more ideas on how we could
put such an amazing technique to use?
Let me know in the comments below.
Thanks
for watching and for your generous support,
and I'll see you next time!